In this homework assignment, we asked you
to do a few optimizations. The very basic
optimizations you can do are very, very
simple optimizations on binary operations, on
basic arithmetic, and the ones we specifically
asked you to do are these right here as well as
replacing expressions with constants when
applicable. So we gave you this one right here
and then, to add in the others, we just do this
great big ‘else… if…’ statement. So the first
one, we check that the operation is times, we
check that A is a number and it’s a number
equal to one. And if it is, well, one times
anything is that second thing, is B. So we just
returned B. We don’t have to wait and run this
through once we’re interpreting. That would
take more effort than we need to. Now we do
the same thing with the next one if B is one
and A is something else. We can just return A.
Now we can do the same thing with addition
and 0. We just check if the operation is equal
to plus and that A is a number and it’s a
number equal to 0, then we return B. If B is a
number equal to zero, then we return A. And
finally, the last one that we asked you to
implement is a number minus itself is 0. So
that’s fairly straightforward too. Check if the
operation’s equal to minus and then if A
equals B – and remember, you can do that
because you can check if Python tuples are
equal to each other, not just numbers – then
we return a tuple of number and 0 to indicate
the number 0 in our abstract syntax tree. Now
the constant folding is a little bit more work,
but really not too much. First, we check that
the first element of the tuples A and B are
number. Then if the operation is addition, if
the operation equals plus, then we return
number and second element of A and B added
together. So that way, we don’t have to run
that operation later on when we are actually
running the program. And we can do the same
thing if we check if the operation is minus,
then we run – then we return tuple of number
and the second element of A and B subtracted
and similarly for multiplication. We can just
do the same thing for the second elements of
A and B, multiply together. And then once we
have hoped that the operations have been
optimized in some way, we wrap it back up in
a binary operation and a tuple of BinOp, AOP
and B, and return that. And if none of this
worked, if we didn’t even get a BinOp to
begin with, then we just return the expression
because those are all the optimizations that we
have done. So let’s try that with a few of these
test cases and these are the test cases that we
provided you with. So we have zero, one and
two, numbers equal to 0.0, 1.0 and 2.0, and a
few variables that are ancient kings and
queens of Persia and Macedonia – Xerxes,
Darius, Antiochus and Musa – and then we’re
going to define a plus operation, just so we
don’t have to keep writing this tuple out, and a
minus operation and a times operation
similarly, just to save some key strokes. And
then we’re going to check whether an
expression that we’ve said, which is times 2
and 0 is equal to 0. That is their optimization
actually ran. We’re going to do the same thing
with a minus operation and a slightly more
complicated operation. Expression three is
minus plus zero plus one plus two zero two.
That was a quite a big mouthful, so let’s go
through it just a bit more in-depth. Plus two
and zero, so two plus zero and then we wrap it
in this call to plus, so two plus zero plus one
and we wrap it again in a plus zero, and then
we wrap all of this up and subtract two from
whatever this is. So this really should just be
three minus two. Once you get past all of the
massive amounts of parentheses. So we print
out and make sure that that is indeed equal to
one. We do the same thing for these
expressions as well. So when we run this, we
see that we pass all of our test cases. And this
– our test cases involved a bunch of hand-
checking, where we just made all these up and
hand-checked that this is what they’re suppose
to be and then verified that the optimization
actually does what we think it’s going to do.
This isn’t necessarily how you would
normally do it, but it’s good enough to serve
our purposes right now.